this video is brought to you by
brilliant to learn more about brilliant
please go to brilliant org forward slash
bio graphics or click in the link below
more about brilliant later in today's
video now if I were to ask you to name a
famous nurse there's a very good chance
the ad responds with the name of a 19th
century woman Florence Nightingale is
almost the archetype of nurses a wealthy
woman who gave it all up to devote
herself to caring for the sick she's
still pictured today as she was during
her heyday in the Crimean War carrying a
lamp from sick bed to sick bed tending
to the wounded but how many of us know
the woman behind the myth born is
privileged in the early 19th century
Florence Nightingale was a polymath a
genius he spoke multiple languages and
pioneered concepts of statistical
analysis that are still used today a shy
devout Christian she was a feminist he
thought women shouldn't vote celebrity
who wished only to be forgotten and a
nurse who oversaw a hospital with one of
the highest death rates in modern
history a complex woman full of
contradictions this is the life of
Florence Nightingale
[Music]
or words spring to mind when you hear
the name Florence Nightingale we're
guessing it's something along the lines
of nurse or angel and probably lamp
what Robley don't spring to mind words
like borderline genius born on May the
12th 1822 English parents in the city of
Florence no prizes for guessing where
she got her name there Florence
Nightingale had the sort of brain that
only comes along once in a generation
her parents were super connected super
wealthy English socialites who valued
education even for their two daughters
this was kind of a big deal at the time
when being born with two x-chromosomes
was the quickest shortcut to a life of
knitting wearing corsets and fainting
whenever someone mentioned long division
luckily for baby Florence her father had
always dreamed of passing on his own
Cambridge education to his children and
hid be damned if he was going to let
those children being female stop him
there's actually some evidence the Papa
Nightingale had expected Florence to mia
boyens he refused to accept reality he
encouraged the villagers on his estates
to refer to the young girl by the male
title of Squire
regardless Florence's early life was
spent in a blitz of learning that would
leave an on a student's head spinning
Shearer asked a French German Greek
Italian and Latin she memorized works of
philosophy into it debated them with her
father she also got super into maths to
the extent that she begged her parents
to go study the subject at university
that her mother said no it was not long
after that Florence she had a vision now
he really needs to be a bit careful with
the word vision here because that comes
as you know images of Joan of Arc
communicating directly with God
Florence's vision it wasn't like that it
was more than anything a bit of a
feeling and a certainty that God had
given her a silent command still the
effect it was dramatic on February the
5th 1837 the sixteen-year-old Florence
declared God had told her to end
suffering in the world she interpreted
this to mean that she should go into
nursing this time her mother and her
father both told her no in those days
nursing was considered barely above
prostitution the idea that an
upper-middle-class girl could go into
the profession was so radical that even
Florence
liberal father refused to consider it
but if mum and dad thought that they
could keep Florence from her calling
while they had another thing coming over
the next 13 years Florence tried again
and again to change her parents minds in
1844 Florence tried and failed to
convince her parents to send her for
nurse training in Salisbury in 18-49
Jeevan ditched a long-term suitor
Richard Moncton Milnes so that she could
focus on her non-existent career by the
way around an aside here it later
transpired that this suitor was heavily
into sadomasochism so maybe she kind of
dodged a bullet there maybe but Florence
was persistent and she kept working away
her parents all the way through her
teenage years right into womanhood
by the time 1850 rolled around she was
30 and her father was utterly worn down
that July her parents gave her
permission to travel to Germany for a
two-week training course at a nursing
Hospital perhaps they thought that being
up close with all that disease would put
her off a life of nursing but well that
didn't happen the next year Florence
returned for another course this one
lasting three months by 1853 Florence's
dream had finally been realized using
her family connections she got a job at
a hospital for distressed gentle woman
on Harley Street in London it wasn't
hugely taxing but it was definitely
nursing finally forints Nightingale had
made it well it was just the warm-up act
Franz Nightingale didn't know it yet but
she was about to get sucked into one of
the bloodiest conflicts in European
history
[Music]
in 1853 the European continent was
haunted by the specter of a sick man
the Ottoman Empire had once been one of
the finest empires history ever produced
at its height it was an epicentre of
science and art capable of taking
territory all the way up into Austria by
1853 though his glory days were over
hobbled by stagnation secession and wars
of Independence the Ottoman Empire was
now staggering on the fringes of
geopolitics being known as the sick man
of Europe as the invalid Empire hacked
away on its deathbed another Empire
sensed an opportunity in the Russian
capital it was lost on absolutely no one
that had I got a man's statement a
chance to snatch territory from the
Empire's fringes at the same time in
Paris and London it was lost on
absolutely no one that a territory
Hungary Russia posed a real threat to
all of them in October of 1853 all these
different strands well they finally came
together under a pretext of defending
Orthodox Christians living in the Sikh
Empire Russia made its move the Turks
declared war which pulled in Britain and
France and suddenly the area around the
Black Sea was alight with conflict it
was the start of the Crimean War and it
would end somewhere in the region of a
million lives we could easily spend the
next 20 minutes describing this complex
forgotten war but for our purpose today
there are two things that you need to
understand about the Crimean War the
first is that this is the first war in
which the modern media was involved the
first war correspondent in history
William Howard Russell was there for the
Times of London sending back real-time
reports for the newly invented telegraph
the second is that military hospitals
were very different from what we would
expect now nursing soldiers during
wartime it wasn't something governments
did since medieval times it had usually
been religious orders like the Sisters
of Mercy who took care of the wounded
and the Crimean War erupted though the
British government was so against the
idea of sending women into a conflict
zone that they actually forbid any
nurses from going this mends the injured
British troops were receiving a level of
care that was so basic you could program
computers with it yes that was a
terrible coding Bannen no we're not
sorry the OP shot is that these two
points overlapped when William Howard a
Russell decided to write about British
military hospitals in Crimea and send
back reports so graphic that they caused
outrage
caught back footed the British
government quickly reversed its no
nurses on the frontlines policy suddenly
secretary of state at war Sidney Herbert
found himself in dire need of a head
nurse to send to Crimea luckily he had
just the one in mind many years earlier
in the 1940s Herbert and his wife
Elizabeth had been visiting Rome when
they happened to bump into a vacationing
Florence Nightingale the three hit it
off and remained close friends when they
returned to England and so it was in
1854 that Herbert was able to write to
Nightingale and ask her to go to Crimea
for ins Nightingale actually jumped at
the chance but at the head of 38
volunteer nurses the 37 year old left
behind a hospital for gentle women and
got on a boat on October the 21st 1854
it was supposed to be a dream come true
a chance to show her parents what she
was really capable off instead Florence
Nightingale would soon find herself
trapped at the center of a nightmare
[Music]
on November 5th 1854 ferns Nightingale
and to corps of nurses arrived at the
british military hospital of Scutari
today cyber of Istanbul what they found
there was something that would haunt
them for the rest of their lives the
hospital was built atop a sewer which
had flooded long ago and no one had
bothered to plug it when injured men
walked into the toilets they had to pass
barefoot through a layer of ankle-deep
feces
there were rodents running amok men
lying in filthy bed clothes that hadn't
been changed for weeks on end there was
rotting meat lying around from where
patients were supposed to cook their
meals there were people with unwashed
gangrenous wounds this place was a human
cess but a place where pestilence and
disease roamed the hallways trailing
death in their wake the shock was so
great that for the first few days it was
all forints Nightingale could do to keep
functioning the military brass made it
clear that after she landed they didn't
want her rocking the stinky
disease-ridden boats so she tried not to
she really did
this became tricky though after November
the 10th on that day the British wounded
of two major battles arrived in Scutari
the hospital look ready in dire need of
supplies effectively ran out it was
during this time when she was surrounded
by squalor and misery and the screams of
the dying that Nightingale famously
called a new hospital the kingdom of
hell but the experience it gave her the
kick up the rear that she needed to keep
moving
another how he said that France
Nightingale was sooo bit into math as a
teenager well she started crunching the
numbers for the hospital to our
amazement she discovered the war
injuries and killed around 4,000 people
in the hospital that year
sickness on the other hand had killed
19,000 this wasn't a hospital this was a
charnel-house soldiers were coming in
with treatable injuries and they were
leaving in coffins faced with an army
determined to keep doing things the old
way Nightingale had no choice but to
start trying to save those soldiers
herself this is the part where we get to
the legendary image of forints
Nightingale the nurse walking the wards
oft dark armed only with her lamp
offering succor to the dying certainly
this happened nightingales nighttime
visits became a fixture of the wounded
men's lives but really this romanticized
image is just a sideshow the important
stuff was happening behind closed doors
in meetings with army all
versus Nightingale insisted on basic
standards of cleanliness ATS qatari
including regular bathing of patients
and changing of bandages on wounds at
the same time she campaigned for the
opens who are flooding to the lower
floors to be repaired
something we're having trouble believing
that she actually needed to campaign for
at all
of course kindness and closing sewers it
doesn't make good copy so the newspapers
that wrote about the lady with the lamp
focused more on a bedside manner these
were the tales of Florence Nightingale
helping the wounded write letters home
of the nighttime visits that she made to
keep the men's spirits up incidentally
the reason nightingale was the only one
to visit the wards at night was because
the other nurses were forbidden from
doing so Nightingale thought they would
have sex with the male patient so banned
everyone else from roaming around after
dark it's just a random historical fact
that we really couldn't fit anywhere
else before long the men whose qatari
had grown to love their ministering
angel and the British public had grown
to love her too that's right Nightingale
became a celebrity the tales of her
selfless good work were exactly the sort
of tales that Britain needed from a war
that had produced no heroes this reached
its apex on February 24th 1855 that day
a London newspaper published an
engraving of Nightingale with her lamb
overnight this random nurse working in a
British military hospital became more
than just a woman she became a symbol
the days of Florence Nightingale the
human they were over and the day is the
Florence Nightingale their lady with the
lamp had arrived now just before we get
into the myths and legends that surround
France Nightingale I do want to take a
moment to tell you about today's sponsor
brilliance brilliance are a science and
learning platform that allow you to
learn through active learning which
summed up is basically the opposite of
that feeling you know where you read a
really long complicated paragraph in a
textbook and you just read it again them
again you don't really get it because
you don't have to do anything with that
knowledge it's just not the best way to
learn and brilliant don't just cover the
basics although they do cover those as
well they go through complicated things
even as far as complex statistics so I
think I would have liked that one now
you've heard me talk a bunch about
brilliance if you're a regular viewer
and I think you know that I think it's a
perfect fit for this channel because
well the or watching a 20-minute
educational video on YouTube so you're
probably into learning and
I think brilliant is a great way for you
to expand on that recently brilliant
made an important update to their mobile
app so the courses can now be accessed
offline so you don't have to worry about
having a solid internet connection to
learn things through their platform so
maybe you could spend your commute
jumping onto brilliance and learning
something brilliant makes even complex
concepts easy to understand they give
you something super short to read it's
easy and then you immediately apply it
to the problem and just rinse and repeat
that and suddenly you're understanding
all sorts of stuff that you didn't think
you would be all course is a very
interactive so you can learn probability
by playing a game of blackjack or learn
the physics of motion using interactive
models of pendulum clocks so if you want
to support bio graphics which would be
great and get unlimited access to all of
brilliance in-depth maths and science
courses you can head over to brilliant
dot org forward slash and by graphics
and get 20% off that annual premium
subscription and let's go back to the
lady with the lamp shall we
today the truth of Florence Nightingale
has almost been lost to the myths
swirling around her name both good and
bad for example you've maybe heard of
House qatari actually had a higher death
rate under Nightingale whose reforms
were more often than not fatal for
patients this is a tale that's cropped
up for on places as venerable as the BBC
and it's also like the complete bullcrap
actual Nightingale scholars like mark
vos trijet atamans that it's based on a
misreading of the data sort of like how
you might look at the way World War two
combat deaths spiked after September
1939 and conclude Winston Churchill was
the bad guy yeah deaths at Scutari
jumped under Nightingale but that's
because she arrived just as supplies ran
out and the hospital exceeded capacity
now that's not all to say that the lady
with the lamp was always a saint though
the same time Nightingale was its qatari
around 1855 a British Commission looking
into sanitation proposed similar
hospital reforms to hearse to this day
something Nightingale essentially stole
their ideas and passed them off as her
own then there's the issue of Mary
Seacole a half Jamaican doctors who
used her own remedies Seagal travelled
to the Crimea under her own steam and
set up a hospital on the peninsula to
treat second officers she and
Nightingale were aware of one another
and didn't like each other very much
the some evidence Nightingale myth
refused to let Seagal join her nursing
Corps due to her race on the other hand
suggestions that heightened Gale took
credit for Siegel's innovations don't
seem to have much grounds in historical
sources come 1855 though Nightingale was
a hero of the British Empire back in
London a fund had been set up in her
name that would eventually raise 45,000
pounds the equivalent to a really giant
pile of money in today's pounds the
nurse had also won respect for getting
her hands dirty on a trip to Crimea
itself she'd been badly sickened and
nearly died while the papers celebrated
our recovery no one knew that should
picked up Bruce aleosis a recurring
infection that would soon leave her
badly disabled but that was all in the
future until the war ended all Florence
Nightingale wanted to focus on was
caring for patients on March the 30th
1856 and it finally did the Treaty of
Paris was the end of the Crimean War and
the slaughter that had killed a million
that changed really very little those
millions that had died by the way almost
all of them
were carried off by disease after the
war ended Nightingale stayed on in
Scutari to help close the hospital
before finally departing herself on
August the 7th 1856 she arrived back in
Britain to a hero's welcome people they
treated her like the second coming of
Elvis and Nightingale she absolutely
hated it as she Saurus the hysteria over
the lady with the lamp was just a way of
distracting from the real issues and
that was the reform that the army
medical establishment desperately needed
in the end she decided that she was just
gonna have to push through these reforms
herself
[Music]
in the mid 19th century if you got sick
there was only one explanation miasma
miasma theory is well those things you
sometimes hear about in history and they
sounds so screwy you almost can't
believe people actually thought it was
real basically people thought that
diseases were caused when bad smells the
cholera you might contract from raw
sewage that wasn't because of germs but
because of the smell of poo not long
before the Crimean War miasma theory had
become so widely accepted that the
British government actually approved a
plan to drain sewage into drinking water
because that would be less harmful than
letting it pong on the surface by the
time Florence Nightingale came along
miasma wasn't the only theory in town
many medical professionals were sounding
alarm bells that maybe this new germ
theory was where it was at
but miasma was still the theory British
politicians and Army Medical brass
believed but Florence Nightingale was
about to explode all of that about as
effectively as a stack of dynamite after
her return home Nightingale devoted all
of our energy and intellects getting a
Royal Commission established so that she
could look into preventable deaths in
the Crimean War but the army they
stonewalled her so therefore Nightingale
teamed up with government statistician
William Barr to provide evidence that
something did need to be done in 1856
statistical analysis was at the cutting
edge of modern science all those lovely
easy to understand chance that you see
on Nate Silver's blogs they simply
didn't exist yet the fact that they do
now is in part thanks to Nightingale and
bar for roughly a year the two worked to
crunch the data by hand they compared
the records of the hospital at Scutari
to a London military hospital and then
also to a Manchester civilian hospital
as a control the excellent podcast
called bedside rounds details this and
really their episode on France
nightingale is a great resource for
understanding her statistical
breakthroughs so I'd recommend you go
check that out
now miasma theory suggests that the
hospital in Manchester should be the
worst of all Manchester in 1856 was a
choking billowing cauldron of stench it
was everything that miasma believers
feared but Nightingale and Barnes data
well it showed something very different
the death rates in the Manchester
civilian Hospital were far below those
in the London military one while the
death rate in Scutari had
initially outpaced even the London
hospital after nightingales reforms it
had dropped into second place a military
hospital in the civilized British
capital had a higher death rate than a
field hospital on the edges of an active
war zone as Nightingale put it
sanitation in British army hospitals was
so bad it was akin to taking 1,100 young
men out on to Salisbury Plain each year
and shooting them dead
when Nightingale and Barr presented
their findings they did so visually
using what would now call a coxcomb
graph it said that this was likely one
of the first times in history data was
ever presented visually that made it
easier to understand when the government
saw her graphs Nightingale was
vindicated a major review of army
medical standards it was undertaken with
sweeping effect the reforms the lady
with the lamp at first started all the
way back in Scutari were implemented
across the board including methods for
cataloguing disease and death rates that
were still in use well into the 20th
century by the time the British Army
intervened in China's bloody Taiping
rebellion in the early 1860s florence
Nightingale's recommendations had so
taken roots that the death rate for
soldiers from disease was 90% lower than
it had been in the Crimean War the
nightingale
this was a major triumph the last
half-decade of her life had been
consumed with forcing Army Medical
culture to change and now here she was
directing those changes but there would
be no time for celebration in 1857
Nightingale suffered her first collapse
due to the Brucella osis infection that
should picked up in Crimea in no time at
all the disease had emaciated her she
lost all her hair she lost weight she
became effectively bedridden often
suffering pain so acute that she was
unable to work for the rest of her life
Britain's most famous nurse would live
in agony
from a physical standpoint that was
pretty much it for Nightingale after
coming down with her illness she
retreated to bed and she never really
left
but while she'd never again go as far
away as Crimea the polymath nurse wasn't
done yet
in fact she was just getting started
confined to her bed Nightingale started
writing letters hundreds of them
thousands of them campaigning letters
going out to all corners of the country
outlining the need for major medical
reforms and that's not all she did
remember how people in Britain raised
45,000 pounds for her while she was in
Scutari well Nightingale took that money
and used it to fund a secular nursing
school st. Thomas's Hospital in London
the Nightingale school wasn't the first
nursing school in Britain but it was the
first that fulfilled three strict
criteria one IRRI secular to developed
its program in line with scientific
advances and three it treated nursing as
a career no longer would nursing be
something for nuns and the lower classes
lighting girl wanted to make Nursing a
legitimate profession you can see she
succeeded just by looking around you
today nowadays those who've seen her
sing as synonymous with prostitution are
strictly stupid horny men with a tragic
thing for uniforms but this is where it
all started
nightingale school is the first to give
nurses good pay sick leave and annual
vacation perhaps most importantly though
the school encouraged nurses to travel
just head up schools in other countries
and to pass the message on within a few
years Nightingale nurses had fanned out
across the British Isles a few years
after that they were establishing
schools in America a few years after
that they were even setting up hospitals
in Japan as they went the Nightingale
nurses took some core tenants with them
nurses should be separate doctors rather
than merely subordinate they should
enforce cleanliness and the washing of
wounds and health care should be
available for everyone if you live in a
nation with universal health care it may
well be in part thanks to Florence
Nightingale from her bed the great
medical reformer tirelessly advocated
for equal treatment of the poor by
nurses and doctors it's this belief that
eventually evolved into Britain's modern
NHS of course there was more to
nightingales last years than just
medicine she gained the first female
Fellow of the raw statistical Society
she advocated for minority rights
across the British Empire she also wrote
one of the key texts of 19th century
feminism Cassandra a book detailing how
intelligent women are often ignored by
less intelligent men which unfortunately
still seems pretty relevance but perhaps
the most interesting thing about
florence Nightingale's later life is how
private it was famously prickly the now
elderly lady with the lamp hated
receiving visitors she hated having a
picture taken she hated being reminded
of her fame towards the end of her life
she declared I only want to be forgotten
and she changed her world to stipulate
that she should not have a public
funeral finally on August 13th 1910 she
breathed her last for the British public
it was like a symbol of the nation have
been lost despite her pleas for a
private funeral people lines the road
all the way to nightingales final
resting place government ministers made
speeches at a special services in Paul's
Cathedral
although nightingale had specified that
she wanted to be buried in an anonymous
unmarked grave she was finally put to
rest beneath the headstone bearing her
name at st. Margaret's church today The
Legend of Florence Nightingale it's
still going strong she's endured as a
symbol in a way that few ever will every
year nurse is still carrying lighted
lamps into Westminster Abbey in London
to mark the passing of the lady with the
lamp it's a touching ritual it's
poignant there's also something miss
Nightingale probably would have hated
Florence Nightingale she didn't want to
be remembered she didn't want to have
lamp like processions and YouTube videos
about her life she simply wanted to
vanish to be anonymous but sometimes
someone lives a life so great the
forgetting them simply isn't an option
when France Nightingale was born women
were considered incapable of
understanding concepts like statistics
Nursing was considered unsuitable for
middle-class girls being healthy meant
not sniffing smelly air the fact that
Florence Nightingale was able to not
just challenge all of these assumptions
but help overturn them explains why
she's remembered today born into a world
with a glass ceiling solo is practically
a cage nightingale managed to smash
through it and in doing so she changed
the world she may have been named living
legends who wish to be forgotten but she
was also something else a symbol for
both the wounded and the dying and those
who wish to tent for them she was if
nothing else the lady with the lamp so I
really hope you enjoyed that video if
you did
give us a thumbs up below and don't
forget to subscribe we've got brand new
videos just like this several times a
week also hit that Bell button so you
find out about them if you're looking
for more from me why not check out my
other channel called top 10s that is
linked to below and as always thank you
for watching
[Music]